uh battle formations we're going in hey
hold up copy that crunchy my Falcon is
green hey hey hey we can talk about our
Falcon colors when we get back to base
Black Falcon right now we got a mission
to do fall into Falcon formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order I'm not gonna
know you're talking to me
I'm not in a Black Falcon come on chill
it out black falcon yeah Black Falcon
relax first of all I don't like the way
you guys are saying Black second of all
there is no Black Falcon I'm green
falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
don't talk to me like that no don't say
Grill like that I'm the green falcon and
I oh stopping some Black Falcon about it
what the do you mean by that